it is December 8th 2022 and you're
watching the code report I've been
trying to warn you about this for years
artificial intelligence is coming to
replace programmers over the last few
days the world has been freaking out
over chat GPT a new demo from openai
that can write and analyze code among
many other things the tool itself is
very impressive but it's not going to
replace programmers it can really only
solve trivial problems like GitHub
copilot and often it provides answers
that are just flat out wrong but look
correct to someone without the proper
domain knowledge it's already been
banned by stack Overflow because the
site has been flooded with people
posting AI answers on topics they know
nothing about more than anything I think
chat GPT is an existential threat to
tools like Google and stack Overflow
because it's a much faster way to get
answers to basic programming problems
what's crazy though is that this is just
a general purpose tool it's not even
designed for programming specifically
now just imagine what will happen when
this technology is focused on replacing
programmers here's how I think it might
play out over the next few years first
AI will start to take over as the
decision maker on your actual machine
Microsoft has already developed codec
CLI to bring AI to the command line
instead of learning Linux in the near
future you should be able to just tell
AI what you want and it will run all the
necessary commands for you automatically
that technology is essentially already
here what I expect to happen next is
that AI will start to build out entire
projects for you based on the
requirements that you give it kind of
like test driven development where all
you do is write some basic testing code
then AI installs all the packages
creates all the files and writes all the
code for you it'll be able to run the
app itself find any errors and correct
them eventually it will get so good that
you don't even have to worry about the
code it writes and this will lead to a
whole new class of artificial
development environments copilot has
already been very successful but it's
just the beginning of this Brave New
World for front end development I would
expect these tools to look kind of like
figma but with extra controls to make
everything interconnected and
interactive to work on any app platform
on the back end we might have something
that looks like a diagram or flowchart
that describes a bunch of API endpoints
or microservices now all of this will be
in integrated into a single environment
allowing the AI to infer the database
models and resources needed to execute
the project and not just make it work
but also optimize it in every way
imaginable in a matter of seconds it
could generate the project in multiple
different languages with multiple
different Frameworks to figure out which
one performs the best actually no it
could create its own brand new
JavaScript framework that is perfectly
optimized for your requirements actually
no why would we even need JavaScript at
that point programming languages are
just for dumb monkeys AI will be able to
write a raw executable straight from
machine code it can come up with its own
perfectly optimized compiler on the Fly
then write comprehensive documentation
about it in any language ultimately what
I think this might lead to is a
universal AI driven programming language
a single deterministic language that
turns every human into a coding God by
simply describing your vision the AI
will figure out how to arrange the ones
and zeros to make it a reality in fact
when we get our neural links we won't
even have to write anything down we can
just think it and it will appear now I
realize neuralink has killed almost all
the monkeys and pigs that have tried it
but when they they open up human trials
in six months I'm gonna be first in line
this language will be so undeniably
powerful that virtually everything else
in the world becomes obsolete overnight
the world will still need Engineers to
solve problems but writing code will not
be one of their responsibilities it'll
become an esoteric skill that only
weirdos take the time to learn kind of
like Celestial navigation I for one
think this is an awesome outcome writing
code is just a means to an end the
reason I learned to write code in the
first place was because I wanted to
build cool stuff if AI can help me build
cool stuff faster without the need to
learn a new JavaScript framework every
week then I will gladly bend the knee on
second thought though it's very possible
that none of this will ever happen I
wouldn't be surprised at all if we're
still writing JavaScript and C plus code
50 years from now this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one